[Musique]
à trois mois du déclenchement des
élections la chef du parti libéral
dévoile déjà les promesses avec lesquels
elle espère séduire les québécois son
message est clair contrairement à
françois legault elle verra venir les
crises et saura y réagit on l'a vu avec
la crise du logement on le voit avec la
question de la main d'oeuvre on le voit
avec la question du coût de la vie
toutes les mesures qu'ils prennent sont
des mesures de court terme en réplique
au fameux chèque de 500 dollars
dominique anglade propose de baisser les
impôts d'un an et demi pour cent pour
les québécois de la classe moyenne une
aide à long terme qui leur rapporterait
jusqu'à 1000 $ par année la crise qui a
présentement une crise qui va perdurer
le cpo de même atteint les gens qui ont
de la misère à joindre les deux bouts
des gens comme la misère la pays pour
l'épicerie ça va pas partir après six
mois à partir après un revenant le
garder mais il voyait encore récemment
le parti libéral s'opposait à une telle
mesure mais le contexte a changé
l'économie ralentit l'inflation est
galopante
on a amplement de marge de manoeuvre
pour faire ce qu'on veut faire et en
faisant ce qu'on propose on va aussi
aider l'économie que le parti libéral du
québec est capable de se renouveler
personne ici n'ignore que le parti
libéral un vent de face les récents
débats sur la langue française ont
fragilisé son lien avec les électeurs
anglophones l'éguille des sondages déjà
basses peine à remonter mais les
militants s'accroche il faut être
optimiste il faut pas se fier
nécessairement sondage ya toujours des
hauts et des bas mais on est là quand
c'est emballant pour leur montée sur un
sujet qui divise les libéraux proposent
d'accueillir 70 milles immigrants l'an
prochain avant d'aller consulter les
régions pour connaître leurs capacités
d'accueil on va être la générosité en
opposition orpi le parti libéral n'est
pas encore en mesure de chiffrer ses
promesses mais en les dévoilant
maintenant dominique anglade fait le
pari qu'elle part avec une longueur
d'avancé sur ses adversaires pour que
les électeurs connaissent ces idées ici
alexandre duval radio canada montréal